over a 35-year period we stole something
like 2.7 million between us
um didn't last very long either the most
we ever took in one go was 160 000
and that was between three of us
[Music]
no no nice to meet you nice to meet you
as well
good
[Music]
in a different way the difference what i
was expecting yeah
yeah yeah what were you expecting i
don't know that you still got like
alibaba frosty looking old gazer
i wouldn't rate this without me glasses
what did you get sentenced for i had to
cut an agent for
cocaine it's legit thing i mean it's
legit but it's just how
you use it so they said oh this guy he's
got 50 kilos of this [ __ ]
and he's obviously doing it with cocaine
what else is he going to do with me
and it was just my birthday i didn't get
like i don't do drugs i got given
everything i had cocaine on me i had md
on me i had
cannabis on me had a knife on me i had
about
32 bottles of alcohol in the boot so
they hit me at the right time you know
i think i told i got about five years
eight months what about you you got a
last sentence right
yeah i've got life for um armed robbery
possession of firearms and ammunition
uh conspiracy to rob and possession of
explosives
i had like a sentence in my head if i
got that year or two or whatever that
would make it worth it but
i got way more than that been out now
for about nine months
about you haven't you been out i've been
out uh nine years last week
nine years yeah yeah
what was the most you ever made from
crime
to me a lot maybe not to other people
but to me a lot
i could have had about a grand come in a
day because even tens and twenties and
i'm buying food and i'm buying weed and
i'm buying clothes
i don't really know like i don't i could
have hired three accountants and they
probably still didn't know what my in
and my outs were do i mean cause you
just
you just splash it as you go what about
you how much money do you think you way
more than me than bank spot
over a 35-year period we stole something
like 2.7 million between us
um didn't last very long either the most
we ever took in one go was 160
000 and that was between three of us i
actually had mine in a
tesco's carrier bag under the bed within
about six weeks the bag was empty and
that was it without
bang out again you went for 50 grand six
weeks yeah
you want to spend it fast because if you
get nicked with it
and the police get it back it's
pointless you have done it you know i
mean so we used to get rid of money
quick
nick your money spend your money want
more
eventually get caught go to prison for
many years come out and what you're good
for you're good for doing what you've
done before you went to prison
because prison teaches you nothing and
that's why we could never get out of the
game
money comes and goes and goes that's
true
did you ever carry a weapon when i
became an armed robber
it was tools of your trade you know you
had to carry something in order to
to intimidate and frighten people to
give you their money every time i went
out my house i had to check that i had
at least one weapon with me
one was normally a gun i used to carry a
knife as well as a gun
sometimes i would carry two guns a knife
and a stun gun
the only thing i've never really carried
on the streets and my mate offered me
one time was a box of grenades
for 20 pound each 20 pounds yeah this
was back in the 70s when
you could you could get stuff like that
nicked off army camps
i wouldn't carry a grenade because it's
indiscriminate but i always have to have
something to protect myself
and protect my family and mainly i've
got to say it was from the police
did you carry weapons
i carried a weapon just a knife i say
just a knife it's not just a knife
it's bad but just a knife like just
always in the waist
did you ever use the knife yeah of
course of course
it's not a toy a lot no not a lot not a
lot
i always had a mentality which other
people don't share like if i don't like
that one person it's just that one
person nowadays i think people are like
cool
if i don't like a and able of b and c
then i'll get all of them i'm not like
that i'm like only this person has done
me wrong
i'm not one of these people that were
staffs one of a girl must have been late
2014
lewisham had the worst stabbing rate in
the whole of the boroughs
why do you think that is why do you
think it's it's got worse i think
everyone has to take a bit of the blame
i think police service for a lack of
numbers
i think even parents for the way they
parent people
social media for what they condemn and
what they allow
there's no youth clubs i don't see any
youth clubs i don't know if you do
budget cuts
i couldn't be an mp or nothing because i
would just blame so many people i think
at the moment everyone's so worried
about the eu they're not really worried
about
about about youth people's gonna stab
left right and say no
describe the moment you knew there was
no turning back on crime
for me it was every time i went in to
rob somewhere
you know i i kind of felt the fear but i
couldn't it was never a turning point it
was never a
stop your gun's already half out your
mass already half down
as you walk across the pavement and put
your hand on the door in the premises
you're gonna rob
because by then you've committed
yourself what was the moment you knew
when there was no turning back when you
started you just sit there you regret
something that's what i knew there was
no turning back i know that would
probably deter
some people but with me it's like i'm
far too gone now like
but i probably went from selling two
packs a day to 10 packs a day i was
always smart enough to know what i was
doing was wrong
but i just never allowed myself to get
to the stage to kind of reconcile that
to fix it once i see money i couldn't
stop
i was more into the adrenaline rush the
danger
you know i mean the absolute feeling of
being alive when you were across that
pavement
i was an insignificant kid you know i
mean i used to get bullied and beaten up
by all the other games in that
so when i became in charge when i had a
gun in my hand or a weapon in my hand i
was 10 foot tall
after you're over that initial fear that
initial like [ __ ] that's going to be bad
it's all up it's all like you're ready i
mean it's all positive it's all happy
you love what you're doing and
you must see it things deteriorate
quickly like oh yeah on one bank to two
banks to four banks and
becomes an addiction same as violence
violence can be an addiction as well
yeah yeah generally rush yeah um
sorry describe prison food in two words
absolutely [ __ ]
describe the contraband that was being
sold
rightly have we got an hour
you can buy anything in prison if you've
got the money you can buy anything
knives um dartmouth was favourite for
that and a workshop made prison beds
so you can imagine the knives that come
out of dartmouth workshop you're talking
about sabres and everything and daggers
the only thing you can't buy as a woman
not in british shells fault
of course you can because they used to
have the prostitutes coming from the
outside
yes you're right i think the worst thing
you can buy in prison in the top
security prisons is you can buy
someone's life
and you can get someone killed for
quarter of an ounce of
heroin i think was the main price was
that that 200 pound in the world if that
yeah what things did you do to keep sane
in prison
i keep saying to visit my mum every
month every single month she was there
niece and nephews my sisters those
that's the only thing you look forward
to you must agree that visits are not
the only thing you really look forward
to in prison like
i was i was different i refused visits i
wouldn't let people come in from the
outside because i didn't want the
outside world intruding
onto prison because i think you can't
live with one foot in prison
one foot outside and because my
sentences were very very long
um i kind of like visits weren't for me
so my my way of keeping the same was
causing them as much trouble as i could
all the way through my prison system
anyway i could do it i would do it i'd
make hooch i would sell weapons i would
sell drugs
i would assault screws i would set up
riots i would attack sex offenders
so i've decided to myself listen if you
want a criminal i'm going to give you a
[ __ ] criminal
it was just mental but it kept me going
all the time and it kept my brain taken
over
until i discovered education and once i
discovered education that became my drug
and that kept me sane to me in education
we just we never clicked
yeah we never never really liked each
other in education so
back school all the time i was just
probably scared to be like if i don't
get the result i want i'm gonna look
stupid so i might as well just be the
class clown from there that's where it
all kind of started probably like i got
kicked out two weeks for my gcses had
like nine months out of school
literally this lawyer until next
opportunity arises
everyone has done probably done bad or
wants to be bad in their life goes for a
little stage a little window maybe
13 or 15 where it's cool to be arrested
have blue cards around you look
almost famous i think if you don't
educate yourself
then you can't understand the concept of
rehabilitation that's why so many people
in jail
yeah it's like a revolving door to them
because they don't learn anything they
don't apply themselves they just want to
lay on the bed and watch the telly or
take drugs since going to prison stuff
i've done open university and all this
stuff and i'm learning a language now
but
but you said you've been doing education
since do you enjoy it now
no i don't enjoy it no no i don't enjoy
it i just
i just do it
um what do you do now so in prison i
look at my craft as coffee
my breasts i'm a roadster do a bit of
work do a bit of fixing machines and
stuff like that
so um now i work for a homeless cherry
um who we hire homeless people through
coffee we pay them a living wage all
that stuff
and um hopefully soon sooner rather than
later i'm going to be teaching them how
to
how to make coffee and i also i also
work with them kids with challenging
behavior so probably kids that were like
me
yeah eight years ago or whatever you
must do something you're proud of
yeah when i was in jail i wrote some
books nice become
a pretty uh talented writer and when i
got out i joined inside time which is
the national prisoner's newspaper
yeah and i'm the um
commissioning editor i do a lot of talks
and criminology tours and i go to
schools and young offenders places and
speak to them
and try and let them know that what they
see what they think their impression of
prison is as you well know is not
what it really is and basically try and
put people off if you can stop
one person from going down the line that
we went down
then i think that is a job well done and
it's worth it and i think what you're
doing now is a good thing
sort of thing so
nice one